okay so five kids for president of
United States mr. Obama mr. president
number one number will be okay number
one make sure the whole time and
understand that that dog is what
everybody wants whatever choice you know
so make it so the whole family choose
the right option but the same option
yeah okay so if we have five dogs the
whole family have to choose one and
everybody have to check ants on that and
then just let it go the no the other
four before before we actually go to the
to the dog okay so that's a done deal
number two tick yeah this family needs
to pick a medium level energy dog
regardless of the breed number three
once they meet the dog live emotions
aside meaning excitement and affection
when you meet the puppy number four no
touch no talk no eye contact let the
puppy follow you
and number five walk with the puppy
before you enter in your house said
right away rules boundaries limitations
and then you give all affection in the
world